Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host, Ricardo Lops. And today I'm
joined by Katerina Kovacevic. She is a phd candidate
in the Department of Cognitive Science at Central European
University. Her main research interest is responsibility. She investigates
how people ascribe responsibility for good and bad outcomes
across various situations. And today we're focusing on uh
responsibility and strategic ignorance. So Karina, welcome to the
show. It's a big pleasure to everyone. Thank
you. It's also a pleasure from
OK. So uh actually, this is very interesting because
uh I've already talked about responsibility with philosophers on
the show, but not with someone who approaches it
from a sort of uh psychological slash cognitive science
perspective. So, uh how do you approach responsibility from
that perspective? And what kinds of questions are you
trying to answer in your research actually?
Yeah, that's a good question to make some kind
of a distinction in the approach of philosophers and
psychologists uh to this type of topics. Um The
main difference is that we in psychology approach from
the descriptive perspective, which means that we don't want
to say what is right, what is wrong how
people should ascribe responsibility in which cases, but rather
how people do that, what are people's moral intuitions?
Um And um when do they feel like it's
um um good to, to um ascribe responsibility, what
are some relevant factors for them that influences their
intuitions and their, their decisions? And um when we
talk about the methodology, so how I approach this
um is uh mostly through V studies uh which
is when you write a certain story um about
some hypothetical agents. And then you ask the person
um some questions about their moral judgments such as
um is the person responsible for the certain outcome
um in the story. And since I'm interested in
um different factors that could influence the description of
responsibility, then I just vary uh the context of
the story, what the agent knew what they didn't
know uh what were their intentions and similar to
see whether that would trigger different intuitions, uh moral
intuitions in, in participants. Um Yeah, and also what
psychologists do um when investigating responsibility and some other
moral judgments is uh especially in my department because
I'm a cognitive scientist, we um discover the processes
behind uh this moral judgment. So what kind of
cognitive process lies behind certain intuitions? In my case,
I talk a lot about counterfactual thinking, for example,
that is a thinking of possible alternatives. If this
didn't happen, then something else wouldn't have happened. Um
So yeah, that's like a, a crash course on
what um psychologist does in uh in this type
of a field. Yeah.
OK. So let's get into some of your results
and what we know about how people ascribe responsibility
to others in different kinds of situations and so
on. So when exactly do people as ascribe responsibility
to others?
Um So I will start first from a more
bro broad answer. So, um when I talk about
responsibility, I, I talk mostly in my current research
about responsibility for the negative outcome. Um Then I
see um which factors influence um people to ascribe
responsibility more or less likely. So what are some
kind of a mitigating factors in ascribing responsibility? And
what I be shown by now is that um
something that has been already known um to an
extent that epistemic states a relevant factor, so whether
the agent uh knew what would be the possible
consequences of their actions or they didn't know. So
some kind of beliefs about the situation and what
could happen, the level of knowledge and information. Um
And um moreover, which is not a factor that
I, that I provide in my studies, but it
is important to mention is um intentions that they
don't have. Um So if you have desire to
harm the others, uh then it's more likely that
you will be ascribed as responsible uh for uh
some kind of a bad outcome. But in my
research, I mostly focus on um this peculiar case
of agents, uh, who could have had the knowledge,
um, to see how people ascribe responsibility to them,
um, in, um, so to see how people react
to ignorant agents and how they, uh, distinguish them
from the people who have the knowledge. Um, YEAH,
because it's, it's been shown like, um, that when
you have the knowledge you're more likely to be
responsible but the fact that you're ignorant is not
always escalating. So that's interesting to see when it
is and when it isn't exculpating. Yeah.
So you're mostly interested here in epistemic responsibility, correct?
Yeah, but just a bit of a disclaimer. Um
I, I'm pretty sure that philosophers will have a
different definition of what epistemic responsibility is. Uh WHETHER
there's a duty to know enough about before forming
certain attitudes, how I operationalize epistemic responsibility in my
case is more something like epistemic duty, which is
a duty to get informed before acting. Um And
that means that if you have a certain sufficient
care for other people, you, there is some kind
of a normative expectation that you would take certain
precautionary measures or certain actions to get informed um
before uh doing something that could hire mothers uh
or similar. So that is what I I talk
about when I talk about epistemic responsibility. So basically
that there is um when you have sufficient care
for others, you have epistemic intention, which is intention
to learn the relevant information that leads to checking
and that leads to preventing the negative outcome from
happening because now you have the relevant adequate knowledge
for that.
So let's get a little bit into more detail
here. So what if people act without relevant or
sufficient knowledge in their possession? I mean, are they,
are they held responsible or not or are they
held responsible in particular situations and not others? How
does it work? Exactly?
Well, as uh my b A professor, like to
say, uh the best answer is it depends. Uh
BUT now I will, I will explain why it
depends. Um So what we know by now is
that in a lot of cases, as I already
mentioned to repeat is that uh being knowledgeable um
is um more um being, being more judged than,
than having a lack of knowledge about certain situations.
But the fact that you didn't know about something
uh is not enough. Um IN some cases, for
example, you cannot say if you travel to another
country and you didn't buy the transport ticket, you
cannot say, oh, I didn't know how to use
the machine, um which could be the truth that
you didn't know how to exactly buy the ticket,
but it was your, your obligation to get informed
how to do that. Um So um or when
you produce some kind of um uh very bad
uh consequences, for example, you're a doctor and you
didn't check some important allergy when you are prescribed
the, the, the the medication. Um YOU cannot say,
oh, I didn't know about that because it was
kind of an obligation to get informed about that.
Um But what we show in, in our research
as a very important factor in this case is
whether there was an opportunity to learn the information
that is very important. Um If there was no
opportunity to learn the information, the relevant quant factual.
So this relevant alternative is about some external factors.
So if it would have been possible to learn
the relevant information, then the person would have done
that. But if there was the opportunity to learn
something relevant, but you deliberately chose not to do
that, then you're more likely to be as scrapped
as responsible. Um And concretely in our um experiments,
those agents who uh didn't take the opportunity to
learn that they had were um they ascribe responsibility
almost the same as the agents who knew about
the possible negative consequences. For example, um If uh
you see there is a sign that parking spots
are maybe uh reserved, but you don't really approach
to check it because you're rushing for your dentist
appointment um that's seen as negative and you are
described as responsible. Um STATISTICALLY even the same as
uh as a person who sees that the the
spot is re uh reserved, but just doesn't do
anything about that. So there is something in this
opportunity to learn that people um take is important.
Um We interpret this as that um people think
about um counter factuals that are related to epistemic
intentions. So explain this a bit more what I
mean by this is that people think whether there
would have been uh an agent who had a
better um more sufficient concern for others who would
have done things differently if there is an agent
who uh cared more about the welfare of others.
Um Would he um check if uh if the
spot is reserved and if the answer is yes,
then the person who didn't check if the spot
was reserved is responsible. But then to complicate the
story a bit more, we added some other factors
in, in the question. So now we say, OK,
the opportunity to learn the information is, is relevant.
Um But then we can ask, is a person
always um obliged to use that opportunity to learn
something and maybe intuitively, um we are not expected
to know everything about everything, right? So when it
is very, it is more important uh to get,
to get informed. And one of the interesting factors
that, that, that we write is how effortful this
action of getting the the adequate information is. So
with the hypothesis that if um if the action
is very effortful and too costly for the agent,
uh that will be some mitigating factor, and uh
there will be less expectation from this agent to
engage in the action that is very costly for
them. Um So, um we showed that that this
was the relevant factor and when there were two
agents who both didn't engage um in the um
action of checking, uh the one who needed less
effort uh to do this action um is where
as was described as, as more responsible to give
you an example. Um If you just need to
read the sign uh to check whether the spot
is reserved or not. Um And you didn't engage
in such a simple action that would not be
costly for you, then you are s ascribe responsible.
But if this action involved waiting for a parking
attendant to come and you don't know when he's
coming and you're in a rush because you will
um miss your appointment, then a person, people are
a bit um more um empathizing with the situation
and they ascribe uh less responsibility. So in this
case, when they come back to this counterfactual theory,
we can say that even the agent who had
sufficient care for others uh maybe wouldn't um check
in this situation when the costs are too high.
So there is kind of a benefit of a
doubt given to this to this person. And we
can say that the relevant counterfactual becomes, if the
action was not so effortful, then the agent would
have done it. Um Yeah, so there is some
relevant factor. There are some um other ones, but
let's say these, these are some, some of the
most relevant. We also checked um the weather. Um
THE probability of the navigate outcome happening is what
is relevant. Um With, uh with the idea that
if it is highly unlikely that something uh negative
would happen, are you still asked to, to check?
Um AND to, to put some uh put some
effort in order to, to check what is uh
what is the relevant information about that event or
to prevent? Um But this factor didn't seem to
be uh relevant. I mean, there may be reasons
that uh the probabilities that we had were still
above some threshold, above which it is expected from
people to act. So if, even if it's like
30 40% probability of something negative happening, if the
action is so uh effortless, such as just reading
the sign, you're expected to do it if you
can prevent some harm to others. But this factor
is still a bit uh something that, that is,
that should be researched more. Yeah.
So, I mean, uh it's not the case that
people always hold people responsible. If they haven't gathered
all the relevant information, it depends. Uh I mean,
a little bit on how much effort you have
to put into it to gather all the relevant
information. But I would, I mean, in terms of
the effort, I would imagine that there are particular
instances where people, even if it would take a
lot of effort would still hold you responsible. I
mean, just one clear, I guess example that comes
to mind is in health related situations. I mean,
if a doctor for some reason gets across a
patient with a very rare condition and just because
it's very rare and it would take him or
her a lot of uh uh g uh a
lot of time to gather enough information to really
understand how that rare condition works and how it
might interfere with treatments and other uh comorbidities. For
example, people probably people in that specific case because
they are dealing with a supposed experts would be
less lenient in terms of, I mean, not holding
them responsible, particularly if something bad happens because of
that.
Yes. Um Yes, that's, that's a very important what
you're saying. Um I see two relevant things there
in your example, one is um the responsibility that
comes with the obligations with the roles. So we
can talk about the normative expectations of certain roles.
So um like doctors, lawyers or some certain um
roles in the society that are connected to some
certain behaviors. And we expect more, more uh from
a doctor, especially in this situation than of some
person who is not an expert in the field
and didn't oblige to help others and similar. The
other relevant factor that I see there is mostly
when we talk about health and especially in this
situation where there is a serious rare disease we
talk about a very severe outcomes. Um And this
is something, this effect of severity of the outcome
is something that has been studied. Um um IN
some other context, um uh when, for example, negligence.
Um AND it, it does make a difference, people
ascribe more moral blame uh for agents who uh
who produce more severe um outcomes. Um But in
this context, when we talk about ignorant agents who
didn't get informed and some, some bad happened. Um
Then that, that's a factor that I would, I
would uh like to uh to investigate in some
of my future experiments. What my intuition about it
uh is now is that people are um computing
the the utilities and maybe this now sounds uh
sounds weird but maybe this is the behavioral economist
side of me. Um But I believe that people
do um um consider uh the benefits, cost costs
and benefits. Um And this case, when um the
potential harm is so severe, then um the ratio
between uh the cost for the agent who needs
to put some effort is still lower than the
cost. Um The uh of uh of the agent
who would suffer uh from uh the lack of
this prevention. So, in this case, um the more
severe the outcome is I believe that people hold
more expectations from agents to check the relevant information.
Um I cannot claim this as for my, from
my data, but this is my my, my strong
intuition about this. Um So let's see, maybe some
uh next time I can, I can give you
a empirical answer to that question. Um But yeah,
this, this is what I uh what I think
uh for now.
So uh we'll get back to outcomes in a
second. But let me just ask you one relate
relevant information because I was just thinking about what
people usually consider relevant information to be. I mean,
of course, we would have to look perhaps at
specific cases, specific examples. But for example, going back
to the case of, I mean, relevant information, what
if for some reason, the person cannot have access
to particular kinds of relevant information or if what
people think is relevant information is not even there
because for example, we don't know enough about a
particular disease. It has not been studied enough, there
are particular aspects of it that we don't know
about yet. So, uh I mean, uh basically, what
I'm trying to understand is uh what people tend
to consider relevant information basically.
Oh yeah, that's an interesting question. Well, 11 thing
that I would like to mention here is that
um the factor that I was uh I was
uh talking about previously is this opportunity to learn.
And of course, there is no opportunity to get
some information. Um Even the doctor wouldn't be uh
found responsible if there is just no, the medicine
did not develop to the extent that could help
a person or there is no medication available in
a certain context. And uh of course, in this
case, situations when there is no opportunity to act
differently and then the the relevant quant factuals are
about some external factors, right? But this question, what
is the relevant information? Uh I mean, I'm gonna
get a bit uh theoretical but when I talk
about what the relevant information is, I talk about
information that has the power to change the outcome.
OK. Um And that's true what you say that
it's not always obvious what type of information uh
could change the outcome, right? Especially if you're a
doctor and you need to uh check for multiple
options, then you don't know exactly which information would
answer your questions. But if we talk about um
some other interpersonal relations, uh for example, um you
want to take a car of your sibling um
that you share um the relevant information would be,
does my sibling need the car for today? Um
And um you would call, call them to check
um about this. So, uh sometimes what is the
relevant information is very obvious uh such as in
the case of um checking what reading the parking
sign and reading if the spot is, is reserved
or not, can you park there or not? And
the relevant information is yes or no, right? Uh
Because that could change the course of the outcome
if a person, uh, who needs this space cannot
park there. Right. Uh, BUT, uh, I mean, I,
I agree in some situations, um, what is relevant
to be known, uh, is not so obvious. Yeah,
that's
true. Yeah. And going back to the outcomes because
we've already talked here about how, uh, if it's
a severe outcome, people usually tend to ascribe more
responsibility to the person. But what if, uh, people
get a good outcome even if they didn't hold,
uh, uh, the relevant information that it was just
a good outcome basically by chance. Do, does that
matter to people or not?
Mhm. Um, BUT do you mean there, whether a
person would be responsible? Um, OR for,
I mean, if, in that case, so let's say
that uh, they get, they got a good outcome
but later people learn that it was mostly by
chance because the person didn't really, uh have, uh,
the relevant information. I mean, just basically did things
they went into it blind, let's say, and they
got a good outcome. I mean, does that matter?
Do people care about that at all or not?
I mean, does that over, is that more important
to people than the fact that they just got
a good outcome or not?
Um, THAT, that's a good question when we talk
about responsibility, the way I define responsibility is that,
uh, some certain outcome is needed because responsibility can
be seen as a, um, response to something So
when something happens, we can talk about who is
responsible for that certain outcome. Um But there are
other moral judgments that would take these uh mental
states more into account. And that uh for example,
um um Cushman theory, Cushman is talking about um
this how for um judgments of blame and punishment
outcome is, is uh what is very important and
more important than when we talk about the judgment
of moral wrongness, for example. So in this case,
when somebody, um even when there is no negative
outcome, we can still maybe not talk about whether
the person is responsible because nothing bad happened, but
we can talk about whether they acted morally wrongly.
Um FOR not gathering the right information such as
a doctor who didn't really check for some relevant
conditions before giving the medication that could have produced
some negative consequences. So in that case, I wouldn't
talk about responsibility, but I could talk about whether
it was right or wrong. Um Not to have
a certain information. Um That is the case of,
for example, uh drunk driving, you can be morally
judged for driving drunk, even if you came home
safely by pure luck, right? So we can, we
can judge this action and your behavior as not
being the good one, but we cannot make you
responsible for an outcome that didn't happen, right? Um
This is my take on this, that uh when
I talk about responsibility in this case, I talk
about the, the responsibility for something that happened, um,
some people would maybe talk about responsibility, like, um,
and that assigning responsibility to people to do certain
actions, like some kind of obligations. But, um, I
talk mostly about the, the responsibility for the harm
that, that happened in this case but we're sure
we can talk about whether the, the, the, the
lack of knowledge, uh, was bad. Right.
Mhm. Right. So let's get now into strategic ignorance
since we're talking about also epistemic responsibility here. I
guess that this ties very well to that. So
what is strategic ignorance? Exactly.
Yes. So we talked about different situations in which
agents are ignorant, right? And there can be multiple
causes why somebody um it was left ignorant. Strategic
ignorance is this specific situation uh when uh people
are using as Dan and colleagues say this moral
wiggle room, uh what it means it means that
since we talked about how in um a lot
of cases, the fact that didn't, didn't know that
something bad can happen, can mitigate the responsibility. People
can use this space to say, oh I didn't
know such as this case with not buying a
transport ticket. Oh I didn't know how to buy
a transport ticket. Um So I'm I'm not responsible
for um I shouldn't be punished for this, right?
So strategic ignorance is ignoring some relevant information in
order to run away from uh the responsibility of
of your actions. Um In my case, we call
it fearful ignorance, but still in these cases, um,
that I mentioned to you such as a person
not checking the parking sign, um, we can say
that the person did that on purpose so that
they are not late for their appointment because in
this case, they would need to change uh the
spot. Uh, THEY would need to park and lose
some time. So they strategically ignore this in order
not to be uh not to feel morally obliged
to change their actions. That's the idea. Um Either
to themselves um or to other people. So basically,
to save some kind of a positive picture of
themselves or they want other people to think more
positively of them. So if you say, oh, I
didn't know I took somebody else's spot, um It's
not the same as saying, oh yeah, I, I
knew that was reserved, but I didn't care. Right.
Um And there are interesting experiments of, of Dan
and colleagues. Um YOU know, dictator games. Um So
this economic games where um you give certain um
um certain um outcomes for people. If you get
six points, a person will, or $6 a person
will get $1. But uh if you choose to
have um $5 a person will also have $5
and then you are asked to choose which outcome
uh would, would you prefer? Um And basically what
these type of games are testing is whether there
is some kind of a uh prosocial, so whether
people would uh also think about other people's welfare
and not only their own, right? Um And when
you show this information transparent like that, so what
is the outcome for you and for the other
person? Um PEOPLE in a lot of cases um
are doing, choosing a prosocial answer. So choosing such
as that they maximize or optimize the developer for
the other person. So what they would rather choose,
rather choose five for both than six for them
and one for the other person. But what's interesting
is that if you cover um what is the
outcome for the other person? And you say it's
50% chance that it's either one or five. Um
So a person who chooses, doesn't know what would
be the possible outcome for the other person. And
then the question is um they, the people have
the opportunity to cover, to uncover this and to
learn what would be the outcome for the other
person. So they have this like uh reveal, reveal
part, the a lot of people they don't choose
to reveal, that's the thing. Uh LESS than 60%
percent of um of people choose to reveal what
would be the outcome for the other person and
why they do this. So they, they con they
can continue choosing more for them without feeling bad
because they have some kind of a benefit of
a doubt or this moral wiggle room. So you
say, well, I choose more for me, but I
didn't know what the other person would get and
they can be, they can save their self uh
self picture. And also how other people see them,
they can be, they can remain perceived as, as
a fair person. That that's the idea of that.
Of course, if they choose to reveal, then people
would choose an option that uh mostly choose the
option that maximizes also the benefit for the other
person. Um So this type of strategic ignorance is,
is, is very interesting. Um But now in real
life, some examples apart from this, not reading the
parking sign and parking wherever you want are um
even some like health related things like you are,
you don't want to know how bad smoking actually
is because uh with smoking or you don't want
to learn particular information about your group that you
belong to because you don't want to um think
more about your group identity and reconsider it. Um
And uh or for example, you don't want to
see how mu how many um sugar, how much
sugar your favorite drink has because you just want
to continue drinking it um and similar. So people
do this in, in a lot of cases that
are related to others or, or just related to
themselves. And um yeah, um and to be able
to uh to continue with doing what they want
to do but still um having some nice, some
good picture about themselves. And there's also a problem
with some certain ecological behaviors that people are ignoring
how they affect the community. The, the, the, the,
the ecology uh because changing their behavior to start
recycling um et cetera can be effortful and not
something that they want to change. Um Maybe some
people would call this rather deliberate ignorance than strategic
ignorance. So this uh terminology is sometimes a bit
confusing because you have uh strategic ignorance, deliberate ignorance,
skillful ignorance, uh et cetera. Maybe I would say
the strategic ignorance is more concerned with this uh
that relates for others to others, such as kind
of this justification. Why you did something or being
perceived as positive in the eyes of other people.
But so maybe I would call deliberate ignorance um
this um behavior that are related to your health,
choices and stuff. Um Hertwig and people from the
Max Planck Institute for Human Development have a lot
of papers on deliberate ignorance. Um And then they
use this terminology. Um So, so yeah, those are
some also some interesting literature to check on this
topic. Who is more interested? Yeah.
Yeah, great. So uh this will probably be my
last uh question. But I would also like to
get into uh perhaps some more concrete example, uh
health care related example. You al you also mentioned
health there. So because the there are particular cases.
And I also read about this in the literature
where people actually use strategic ignorance but are really
a little bit more severe in terms of the
possible outcomes. It can have, I mean, people, when
they read about it, many people think, oh my
God, why would people do that? So when it
comes to, for example, uh, sexually transmitted infections or
ST s, there are actually cases where people, I
mean, they might think that they might have been
exposed to an ST I, and they might have
got it but they don't want to get tested,
uh, in that particular case and sometimes it might
be something very serious like A I DS or
something like that. So, uh, a and in that
particular case, I guess that people find it a
bit weird, that kind of literature because, uh, I
mean, if it's, for example, uh, tobacco use or
if you're, uh, consuming too much su sugar, people
might think that, ok, that's not great, but at
least you're not affecting other people or potentially harming
other people. It's just yourself. But in that particular
case, I mean, there's a very big potential there
that you will be harming other people. And in
that specific, I mean, it, it could be the
case that in a particular case you were exposed
accidentally an sti, I mean, it could have not
been transmitted sexually and you didn't know at all.
And so that's a different thing. But if you
think that you might have got it, then, I
mean, that's completely different, right? So why, why, why
do people do that? Exactly.
That's a great, uh, comment. Now I can get
a bit more personal as to why did they
choose to start working on this topic? That is
not exactly the example that you mentioned, but, um,
how this question of how much should we know?
How much should we check? How much should we
care of not affecting other people? All these questions
were always some kind of my interest. Um AND
this concern for others. But when we talk about
health, it especially arose when I moved to Austria.
So I disclaimer, I moved to Austria in the
time of COVID. So 2021 and in Austria, the
lockdown measures, the COVID testing measures were very severe.
So I moved from Serbia where PC R tests
were not possible to be done by your own
choice. Only if you have symptoms, if you wanted
to do it just to check if you maybe
were exposed, uh or you think that uh you
were exposed or similar, you needed to pay 60
let's say then I moved to Austria where testing
is the easiest thing ever. You just do it
at your home. It's for free. You can do
it every day at the time when I moved.
And then I felt obliged to do the test
almost every day because I felt, what is the
justification of not doing the test it for free?
It's easy. There is no reason not to do
it. So I felt even a bit obsessed with,
with this because I felt so responsible to check,
right? Um And then I was asking this question.
So why do I feel like this, you know
how this moving change these expectations for myself so
much? And um and yeah, I mean, this kind
of a, um, um, thinking that maybe you are,
uh, you have the disease or similar can be
translated to the example that, that you mentioned. And
indeed this uh, question of transmissible sexually transmissible diseases
is very, very important. Um, AND I think I'm
not sure, uh, we could ask legal um, practitioners
but, uh, that even transmitting, uh, transmitting some serious,
uh, sexually transmittable diseases is, um, is illegal if
not to, to, to dis, to disclose that you
have them, right? Um, SO it's a very serious
problem. Um And, um, of course, here we have
the similar, um, motivation for not checking, which is,
um, in case of some uh transmittable diseases, um,
is that you want to continue, um, doing what
you want, um, which is having some, some, some
pleasure and you don't want to talk about that.
You don't want to maybe stop for some time,
uh, and similar. Um, AND then this, there is
this strategic motivation I'm not gonna check because then
I can continue doing what I'm doing. Um, AND
I don't feel so guilty about it. Right. The
other part of that, um, that doesn't include this
lack of care for others, which I would say
it's a lack of care for others if you,
um, have a serious suspicion, especially that you could
be, um, infected, but you don't check the other
part of that, um, is connected with the emotional
regulation, which is also a case with some other
diseases. Um THAT people don't want to know if
they are sick. Uh So even if they have
some symptoms, they are afraid of some um some
negative information, especially if you, if, if some very
serious transmittable diseases are in question that you may
feel uh afraid to learn uh that you have
some of them. Um And this fear is stopping
you from, from checking. Um But of course, I
mean, what my research would say about that is
that um if there is some reason to, to
be suspicious, especially and uh if you have um
and a sufficient care for others that uh it
is expected like that you would have have checked,
especially if it's uh if it's available to you.
But since if we talk about something very serious,
then I get to go back to my question.
People would consider the utility and if it's uh
it's an important uh topic as such here, transmittable
diseases, you could put a bit more effort uh
to find out whether you have something that could
harm others.
Yeah. A and in the particular case of, uh,
STIs, for example. And in the law, II, I
mean, of course, I'm not a law expert or
anything like that and I don't know the laws
of different countries but I would imagine just intuitively,
uh, someone simply suspecting that they might have been
infected and not testing, uh, in the eyes of
the law would be different than actually having tested
and know for sure that you have the disease
and still continue on with the behavior and infecting
other people. Because in the first case, you might
still have some plausible deniability. Right.
Yes. Um Yes, that's true. And as far as
I know, as I think, I know, um this,
uh I like um punishment, uh like legal punishment
for that behavior is only in the case if
you know. Um But since I was working on
this case of beautiful ignorance, I was reading a
lot even about some uh philosophy of law and
some law articles. And in some cases, some philosophers
even claim um that in some cases, the willful
ignorance can be perceived similarly to knowledge. Uh BECAUSE
in, in view of the mens rea which is
this guilty mind and if there was a sufficient
suspicion. Yeah. Um, DID that you could have checked,
that could be also punishable. I think it depends
on the country on the legal system. It's a
question whether it's just like, um, now some kind
of a open discussion, I'm not sure exactly about
this because again, I'm not a legal practitioner just
interested in this topic. So, uh, I come, uh,
to read some, some certain stuff like this. Um,
BUT, uh, yeah, in some cases being, um, having
a reasonable suspicion, such in this case is your
three ex partners of yours told you that they
have HPV, uh, or you have some certain symptoms
of it. I'm not sure how this particular case
would be treated in the legal system. Um uh
OR uh when we talk about um some, some
other diseases. Um BUT uh but that, that um
this reasonable suspicion can sometimes be even enough. Um
Yeah, maybe not in this health context but in
some other context when you're harming others or killing
someone extent. Um AND it's similar, maybe in these
cases, this having enough reasons to be suspicious could,
could lead to more severe judgments. Yes.
Yeah. The only reason why I brought that distinction
to the table between actually knowing that you have
the disease and just suspecting that you might have
it, but not really testing is that psychologically speaking
and from the perspective of psychology and cognitive science,
perhaps uh for people who actually do not care
about harming others and just want to go on
having fun or something like that, then in the
case where they don't test, I, I mean, in
their own self interest. Uh, IT would be better
for them because that, because then they would, if
they are ready, do not care about harming others,
then adding to that they would have more plausible
deniability because I didn't even actually test it. So
I didn't know
that the idea of this moral wiggle room and
that was strategic, strategic ignorance is using this fact
that sometimes not knowing, uh is mitigating your moral
judgment towards you. And you're using this moral wiggle
room of not saying, oh, I didn't know exactly
that's the problem. But what I want to claim
there is that, well, that's, that's not always the
excuse, you know, maybe we're supposed to know, maybe
we're supposed to care more and then if you
cared more, then you will know. And uh yeah,
some, some philosophers would agree with this. Um um
BECAUSE what we do sometimes is as moral psychologist,
we um can take some, some notions from, from
philosophy, some uh prescriptive theories and then test them
empirically. And um some people do talk about the
quality of y and uh this uh recognizing whether
the agent uh had uh in consideration the, the,
the welfare of others, even if come to produce
some negative outcomes. Um They, they would be not
judged as blame, very irresponsible. Um Yeah, so um
yeah, II I want to, to study this more
in my future research, this for sociality and care
for others. Um And how it influences some certain
decisions that we make and certain expectations uh from
people. Um Yeah, I think it's important to take
other people into because I mean, that's my personal
value. I would say uh taking some other people
in the consideration when you make certain decisions and
then to see what, to what extent it is,
uh it is reasonable to what extent people uh
people think it is reasonable. Um Yeah, let's, let's
say like that.
Ok, great. So let's leave it. Uh Let's leave
that as perhaps a teaser for a possible future
conversation once you've finished your phd. So just before
we go, would you like to tell people where
they can find you and your work on the
internet?
Um Yes. So we recently published a preprint that
um is um called, you should have checked and
uh the importance of epistemic intentions in description of
responsibility um with my co authors, Francesca Bonna Lomi
and Christoph Heinz, my supervisor. Um Also you can
find me on the Aces um like the Cards
Aces uh page uh at CEO, which is the,
the name of my lab. Um um So, so
yeah, um those are some, some places you can
find me and there you can see my email
address on the CEO website. Um So yes, if
you, if you have any questions, please feel free
to, to uh to uh email me. Yeah, for
sure. Or always on linkedin, you can find me.
So I'm, I'm on multiple locations.
Ok, great. So Luke Karin, thank you so much
again for taking the time to come on the
show. It's been a real pleasure to talk to
you. Thank you so much.
Thanks.
Ok, great. So Luke Karin, thank you so much
again for taking the time to come on the
show. It's been a real pleasure to talk to
you. Thank you so much. Hi, everyone. Thank you
for watching this interview. Until the end. If you
like what I'm doing, please consider supporting the show
on Patreon or paypal. You can find the links
in the description box down below and if you
like the interview, please share it, leave a like
hit the subscription button and comment. The show is
brought to you by N Lights learning and development
and differently check their website at N lights.com. I
would also like to give a huge thank you
to my main patrons and paypal supporters, Pero Larson,
Jerry Mueller and Frederick Sunder Bernard. So all of
Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whittenberg, Arno Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Alan J con Philip Forrest Connolly. Then the
mere Robert Windier ruin. Nai Z Mark Nebs Colin
hope Mikel Storm Andre Francis for the Agn Fergal
Ken Harl hero, Jonathan lebron and Eric Heinz Mark
Smith Hummels are friends, David Wr Ro Romani Charlotte,
Bli Nicolo, Barbaro, Adam hunt Palo Stassi, Nele Bach
Guy, Madison, Gary G Hellman, Samo Zal, Adrian Yi
Paul Tolentino. Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Bruner Douglas
Fre Franco Bartolo Gabriel Pan Cortez or Lalit Scott
Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy and Smith John Wiesman, Daniel
Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georgina, L Lo A Georges,
Theo Chris Williams and Peter W David Williams the
Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shower, Marie Martinez,
Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D Lee Junior, Old
Harri Bon Starry Michael Bailey. Then Sperber, Robert Grass
is a Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radix Mark
Temple, Thomas Dubner, Luke Neeson, Chris to Kimberley Johnson,
Benjamin GALT, Jessica Nowicki Linda Brandon, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensley Man, George Kiss Valentin Steinman, Per Rowley, Kate
Von Goler, Alexander Robert Liam Donaway br Masoud Ali
Mohammadi Perpendicular, Jonas Herner, Ursula. Good enough, Gregory Hastings
David Pins of Sean Nelson and Mike Levin. A
special thanks to my producers is our web, Jim
Frank Luca Stefi, Tom Ween, Bernard Yugi Cortes Dixon
Benedict Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John
Carl Montenegro, Alick Ortiz and Nick Golden. And to
my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergi, Adriano Bogdan Knits
and Rosie. Thank you for all